millions of americans are dealing with
adhd but there's still a lot of
misinformation and stigma surrounding
the condition attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder affects more than
6 million children and a rapidly growing
number of adults in the u.s a new
documentary the disrupters aims to
educate and reframe how we think about
adhd by sharing the stories of those
living with it in their families it also
highlights many high-profile people who
have harnessed their adhd to great
success here's a clip
i spend
my every waking moment trying to get
outside of my own head because it's a
mess in there it's very busy your brain
is always firing you're firing at a
thousand miles an hour you're eight
cylinders by eight cylinders
24 7 365. it is like i'm juggling 20
balls but i don't remember where they
were in the air i'm just there trying to
kind of catch all these balls and i
remember nothing imagine somebody
sitting on the keys of the computer
that's what your brain is like
that's adhd
that's good we are joined now by the
film's executive producer nancy
armstrong and by dr yamalas diaz a
clinical assistant professor of child
and adolescent psychiatry specializing
in adhd good morning
nancy so this topic is personal to your
family um how so
well this was the film i desperately
needed as a mother of three children
with this diagnosis parenting a child
with adhd can be incredibly challenging
and overwhelming and particularly
because we're still grappling with what
is adhd there's a gross disconnection
between what people think adhd is and
what we know from the science and the
research so i wanted to pull together
the world's experts on adhd
look into five families and how they're
managing the struggle of adhd and then
talk to a number of people about that
are very famous and successful about
their childhood struggle with adhd and
also how they've leveraged their brain
uh to be
some people don't think this is a real
thing
you know and they think maybe you just
have a bad child or your child is
misbehaving number one it's so powerful
so well done the storytelling is
fantastic that i called a couple of
people that i know and said have you
ever thought about adhd because their
child has been told that they have
behavioral problems and so what do you
say to what do we need to do to take the
stigma out of it you know you told the
five families but you didn't include
your own family
well my kids are older now they're 20 18
and 16. and so i really wanted to show
what we went what you went through okay
got it and i think you know
there shouldn't be a stigma around
neurodiversity i think maybe we're at an
inflection point uh now you guys have
done a great job this month really
highlighting that and i think having
well-known people finally come out and
talk about their adhd they also talk
about the childhood struggle but they do
talk about how they leverage the
strength because this diagnosis does
come with some challenges that do need
to be managed but it also comes with
some pretty impressive things yes dr
davis i think it's it's an interesting
diagnosis because i think a lot of
people want to deny it they want to say
it doesn't exist and other people are
reaching for it looking for it as an
answer so what is the state of the
science in terms of diagnosing kids the
state of science is very clear adhd is
very real it is a neurological condition
that is related to very specific uh
differences in the brain that we have
seen for years
low dopamine and certain parts of the
brain that are either over active or
under active it's it's just as real as
any other medical diagnosis but i
understand why people question it
because the manifestation of the
disorder is behavior and so it's easy to
call it bad behavior so you want to
parent bad behavior so i i understand
when parents come to me you know they're
like i've been shouting and yelling and
doing all of these things i feel
terribly about that i'm guilty that they
yeah they feel so guilty with their
child absolutely and they don't realize
that it's there was some reason for the
child's behavior that they could have
parented a little different i like the
framing in the documentary too because
you were talking about you can use it as
your superpower but you have to be
careful with that too but
there's a positive and negative
hyperactivity really means energy
distractibility curiosity impulsivity
creativity it's a matter of framing it
but be careful about just saying it's
just a superpower because there are
still some challenges here
yeah there are challenges and i mean my
experience with my son i mean i should
have known when we got kicked out of
mommy and me class when he was a toddler
but it took years to get that diagnosis
and then with my girls we totally missed
the diagnosis because girls present so
differently than boys do they're not as
disruptive and hyperactive in say a
school setting they they're daydreamers
they fidget they are emotional a lot of
trouble
with friends but they can get through
they're very smart so they get through
elementary school intact and then things
can fall apart in middle school now for
kids that might be at home watching this
um adults that are at home you know what
that's me um what are some of the good
things that we can attach to adhd
because we hear adhd and then behavioral
problems what are some of the positive
aspects strengths are
they're very creative they have a ton of
ideas they're very curious
they have they have tons of energy they
can connect dots whereas like a neuro
neurotypical person sees this and a
person with adhd sees this so they can
connect dots that you wouldn't even
think to connect they're just they're
and they're they're very risk-averse so
they're they're not risk-averse so they
take lots of risk they'll take big
swings at things they can see
opportunities and then act on them
are we just diagnosing this more or is
it happening more because of something
in the environment oh it's good
let's just say one important thing which
is pre-covid we the state of the science
was very clear that the reason we are
recognizing it more and diagnosing it
more is because we have better tools we
have better um you know approach to
assessment and we have reduced stigma so
people know what it's called and they're
coming in to see us so that's a good
thing post covid we still have to see
whether or not we're seeing increases
because kids were home because behavior
problems started to go up because
learning problems started to go up so
we're not sure yet obviously we're still
in the midst of this but um pre-coveted
we know
it was pretty clear thank you so much
nancy armstrong yamala diaz thank you
for joining us valuable information the
disruptors available now on apple tv
plus voodoo and google play